i just feel like personally we're in a
world that's more evolved where back in
the day yes football and basketball are
sports that's more associated with men
and women have worked their asses off
their bloody asses of i'm trying not to
swear guys
um to get to where they are the level of
where they are for example i haven't had
an argument with a guy that said one of
the girls on your team um plays like a
guy and i argued with him and i was like
yo why does she play so many times
why does she play like do you think
because men are better no
sorry
they
like statistically in every category in
every sorry basically scientifically
yeah
so by every measure that you get every
piece of data that you can measure and
then when
[Music]
that she plays she's a pro player yeah
yeah and the guy said she plays like a
guy that's so degrading she worked her
ass off to get to where she plays i
think that's degraded but she looks like
a woman it's not something about who she
is it's not even about women or men but
why is it why is it degrading if men are
bad like they're better because why
would you compare me
like her working her ass off and getting
to that point like to bring a man
okay this is my platform this is my this
is my youtube show pipe down child
respectfully
like why does it matter like why is your
first instinct to get angry when men are
like if we compare if we compare men to
women like they don't get angry like why
is your personality so
because they don't want to be
comfortable like femininity being pinned
on them
and we
like what i'm saying i'm saying i was
like i'm saying like like basketball
right
men statistically in every single i'm
sorry it's not a fun reality but
statistically like like in every single
category are better than women like
there's
like really good high school teams that
beat wnba teams all the time
like right but that's what we need but
we we want credit yeah that's good we
want we could cut out the comparison of
being seen as a man so what if i what if
i said you play what if i say you play
like lebron james would you be offended
no because
so
i wouldn't i wouldn't be offended but
i'd be like so
my
my gifts and my talents are overlooked
to be compared to
an nba player yes
great nba player but i'd be like can i
not be can i not play like jessica can i
not play like me like i understand what
you're saying but just the fact that
women can't be be like oh she's a great
player she she plays like herself like i
wonder how long she took the train
without a lot to get there but to be
compared to
a man it's like okay why can't i why
can't i give you compared to lisa
i can say i got complimented in the
comparison of a woman right and that was
the best feeling in the world because i
was playing beach volleyball one day
yeah and this guy on the court was like
no you're black serena williams but in
volleyball yeah i was like but you were
you you but you weren't offended by that
because because she was a woman and she
paved away for female 1 but i'm saying
like the man did not pave away for us we
did
okay women we're doing it for you
we take bosses and w like in the in
college basketball women's take losses
every year in profits who's making the
profits
that's paving the way
they lose money every single year when
it comes to money i mean just being
strong enough to want to play a sport
that is male dominated for example like
come on tennis
uh basketball all those things
it always started out with men at some
point they were like all right but let's
let women play even baseball they
decided not to let women play baseball
and called it softball yeah
like don't the only time i feel like
it's okay to make extreme
comparisons and differences in the sport
is track that makes sense women are
naturally built different we fully
accept that
so we have to make those exceptions for
us on track but in other sports give
women a little bit more credit you know
we we haul ass too
so they hold it down yeah like if we
look at there's a lot of women there's a
lot of female like if we're going to
talk about basketball or anything i'm
probably coming to volleyball i don't
really pay attention to it like that but
like even in basketball um even football
there's a lot of female players that
actually play better than a lot of men
plays but you never say you'll never
catch like a other a guy crediting them
like that like but
wait are you talking about soccer yeah
yeah yeah are you talking about soccer
but if but if the women
if the women
it's all driven by the market though
like it's driven by by the fans that
want to watch so so if if women weren't
better than men like more fans would
watch they would make more money into
the sport later
is like not the right term like i think
that
like historically like male sports have
dominated and that's kind of the tone
that's set like yeah we can have like a
40-year yeah exactly
also women we don't play like men we
play differently we're correct yes
business and that's genetics yeah
like
yeah women's volleyball is a lot less
like men's volleyball they'll have two
rallies and then it's over because
everyone hits so hard that you can only
do so much with it yeah women's
volleyball's a lot different and that
like there's a lack of interest like
women's basketball you're not going to
see girls dunking every single ball
right
that's not the showboating like you know
what i'm saying so yeah yeah i'm like i
agree i agree yeah i don't appreciate
the
i think it's because
like
obviously men are going to be better
because testosterone is a thing yeah and
they just have more right it's also what
makes them more emotional fun facts yeah
i saw that on this again and so but
but i think it's just the point of like
we we already know men are going to be
physically more better than yeah but why
do we have to have that comparison they
may be a great player they may be a
great athlete but why can't there's also
great athletes as women why can't i be
compared to a woman why do i have to be
compared to a man and so i think i'd
rather be compared to a guy in
basketball because they're better but
there's but there's great but there's no
man like if they said you play like like
lebron james i'd be like dope that's the
best basketball player in the world like
emo that's
up there no i would pick lebron he's
better small person yeah yeah
completely your opinion yeah yeah you
know what i'm saying it's fine it
doesn't like matter yeah
yeah yeah i know that when i was a
teenager and i first started in
volleyball like i was constantly
compared to guys yeah conditions because
i had a very masculine and aggressive
way of playing as opposed to just
straight tactics so it makes sense but i
did take it as a compliment like i never
had an issue with it because i was just
like gang [ __ ] like yeah
when it came to a point where i realized
like
men don't have to be the pinnacle of
power like that's what it is like i'm
a little tired of that narrative like i
want i don't see it i don't think it's
the narrative i see women in media all
the time
like i see women in like and and online
it's changing i see women definitely
yeah so i don't i don't see men as being
like the pinnacle of like 80 of consumer
buying decisions are by women so we're
all like we are constantly being
marketed for women i feel like i'm just
tired of like okay like when you look at
like commercials in the way that um
sports are showed with like men for
example it's always like them with
gatorade and they're like yeah yeah feel
the burn like not really
like you see a tampax commercial and
it's like damn bro like
more than our periods please you can do
your whole life on your period the only
time that you see again like i mentioned
before serena williams like that's like
one of the only athletes that you see in
these commercials like going hard and
going big and it's not about the trend
the girl from track was just in it the
girl from the track team was just in it
the us the us
i was just saying that like they're like
like serena williams like she is so
overly sad because she has like a big
ass and she's like a curvy girl and
she's attractive like that bothers me
too because it's like it doesn't focus
on her skill she's insane oh she isn't
sleeping
absolutely
in a tennis match it's like okay i'm
going to start surprising men your balls
look real good jiggly
touching on that there was a coach i
can't remember where she was from but it
was breast cancer awareness and she had
on pink leather pants and a white top
nothing good she looked great but
someone said is this inappropriate for a
coach i'm like why is that what is it
what if a dude wore tight pants and you
could see stuff and like is that
inappropriate i hate to bring in racism
it's also a racial thing often times
they have always sexualized black women
and at the same time masculinize us it
makes no sense and then discriminates
against it it's like what do you want
because you know you really want all of
that yeah it's like
if you're gonna constantly symbolize us
like get it together dawg like we are
not just
i don't know